in this video we're going to talk about
what is arguably my favorite enzyme and
that is ATP synthase and you might be
able to predict from its name what it
does it synthesizes ATP now you've
probably seen it before we saw it when
we looked at respiration or you will see
it when you look at respiration which is
going on in most of the cells of your
body and you also see it when you study
photosynthesis the general thing that it
does is is it sits across a phospholipid
membrane and through other processes you
will have hydrogen ion concentration
increase on one side of the membrane
have a higher idrija hydrogen ion
concentration on one side then on the
other side you still might have a few
over here and a hydrogen ion is
essentially a proton on so on the this
side of the membrane it'll be more
positive so there will be a
electro-motive force to go to the other
side and also you just have a higher
concentration so there's a chemical
gradient a concentration gradient where
if there's some way for these protons to
get to this side they would want to get
there so there's an electrochemical
gradient that they would want to go down
an ATP synthase provides a channel for
those protons but as those protons
travel through the ATP synthase they
turn this part of it which drives this
axle and then this axle nudges these
parts of the protein so that they jammed
together an ADP with a phosphate group
to produce ATP so down here you going
into this part of the complex you'll
have an ADP and a phosphate group and
then that rotation force that's provided
by that electrochemical gradient that
then produces our ATP and that's going
to be the case both in respiration which
occurs in the mitochondria and in
photosynthesis which occur in
chloroplasts now there's a few
differences in mitochondria the hydrogen
ions these protons the concentration
builds up in the inter membrane space
right over here because of the electron
transport chain
studied that in other videos and then
the protons travel through the ATP
synthase you could see a little mini
version right over it here you could
imagine that what we see really big that
is a blown-up version of this part of
the mitochondria and this is of course
is not to scale so in the case of a
mitochondria this would be the inner
membrane right over here would be the
inter membrane space between the inner
and the outer membrane inter membrane
space and right over here would be the
matrix of the mitochondria and so as the
protons go through they're able to
produce ATP in the matrix now in
chloroplasts the hydrogen protons build
up inside the thylakoids which are these
parts of the chloroplast that space
inside the thylakoids often call the
thylakoid space sometimes called the
lumen that proton build up inside the
thylakoids happens because of the light
reactions the first phase of
photosynthesis but then those protons
will travel through the thylakoid
membrane through this area which is
known as the stroma in chloroplasts and
they produce the ATP in the stroma but
then the ATP is used in the second phase
of photosynthesis to synthesize
carbohydrates which is you could use one
of the end products of photosynthesis so
the big takeaway of this video is one
ATP synthase is incredibly cool if you
look up on the internet you can find
some simulations that show ATP synthase
and how it acts like a motor to jam the
phosphate group to the ADP to produce
ATP and ATP synthase in mitochondria and
chloroplasts are remarkably similar
although they sit in different parts of
these organelles and they the ATP in
mitochondria you can view is the end
product of respiration while the ATP
produced in chloroplasts is an
intermediary store of energy which is
then used to synthesize car
hydrates